le mot casion pu revivre quelques
siècles en arrière avec la fête
médiévale organisée ce week-end pour la
troisième fois
des passionnés organiser un complément
traditionnels et des animations
alors aujourd'hui notre atelier on peut
donc reconstruire notre dame de paris on
peut travailler sur les autres on a fait
des lettrines et des marque pages aux
ocres et on peut aussi reconstruire
l'abbaye de la chaise dieu
le samedi soir l'histoire de la commune
au moyen-âge a été racontée aux
visiteurs notamment à travers la chute
de son château laville même aujourd'hui
garde un lien très fort avec cette
période
maurepas à son village médiéval avec la
tour l'église ya vraiment un village
qu'est moyenâgeuse qui datent de d2 l'an
mil à peu près enfin je raccourcis un
peu mais c'est ça donc voilà oui une
petite et gagne ya une histoire mort pas
yens cet événement attire beaucoup pour
la seule journée de samedi plus de 2000
personnes sont venues notamment cette
famille habitant à maurepas depuis 20
ans on est venus l'année dernière donc
ce toit mais on est
on est super contents parce qu'il ya
plus d'exposants que l'année dernière il
ya eu un magnifique spectacle
hier soir également avec une embrasement
de tours fait part par les services
techniques
c'était vraiment magnifique
[Musique]